okay so i won the first game where i was
lost and then
i've been winning in the next three or
at least
close to winning in the next three and i
haven't won any of them
go figure huh
i wonder what he wants okay he wants to
close the ceiling
yeah that's fine by me
as i said he's a maneuvering player so
it's
really not a surprise that he
that he wants kind of a quiet position
let's go e5
drawer rate feels like the candidates
huh
welcome to to slow blitz
molding and throwing oh this is
interesting
this i had with white against watershed
in the olympiad in tromso and
um
in uh 2014
i don't think i played f4 that early
[Music]
though
can you somehow play
i think you probably probably can go
bishop h3 and ef4
i think you can and then d5
okay so gf
now we've got queen b6 maybe
i think i've seen something like this
before
maybe also d5 is fine
this may be a bit of an overreaction to
um to to his opening play
i think it's fine
so
g2 maybe putting pressure here
okay he just takes interesting
i have to take twice of course
and if i can get most like rook a d8 and
b6
to neutralize the pressure on this
diagonal
then then i should be fine
yeah bishop h3 and
all this probably wasn't great uh
but it's fine
i missed this one
not sure it's a big deal but i
definitely missed it
now this is fine just take and then i go
bishop e5
maybe i'll take with the rock actually
and put the rock on the eight
now let's keep it simple take with the
knight
rookie three i'll go rook e7
d4 i'll take knight c6
okay okay
there's nothing better for him here i'm
at least completely fine
let's see six okay let's just go knight
d5 seems easier
r88
it's probably just going to be a draw to
be fair
maybe you can strive for something
slight with this
bishop but i doubt it and besides some
blitz
getting tricked by the knight is a
series
it's a serious problem potentially
okay now rook d2
you can go take a7 but
this is just a draw
as long as i can get the rook behind the
pawn
and
[Music]
and yeah
and you cannot activate this king i'm
fine and here
i got knight d4 maybe a bishop no bishop
e2 there was 92 in the knight c3
and here i'm
very slightly better but obviously it's
a draw
i'll try and give him a slightly hard
[Music]
time
i mean all of these three against twos
are
drawn but
this a pawn isn't of much use
maybe okay so that's the first
concession
at the very least that's a little
something
now my rook is technically the one
that's
passive but i don't know
if that is the case in practice
so rookie 4 a4
no i can't do anything there
yeah my rook will be passive so this is
just a draw
quite a straightforward one at that
we have to be very very slightly careful
just okay go this way
draw draw draw draw draw